ich hab die taschenlampe akkus gefahr
ich habe ich letztens in dem video
gesagt 70.000 ist schon sehr sehr selbst
geht ich hoffe das schafft er nicht
dann lade ich ein neues horror game
video und dann bin ich jetzt heute mal
nach sechs tagen jedoch dass wir drauf
gegangen und sehr 132000 likes ihr habt
einfach das doppelte geschafft hätte
wegen darf ich euch herzlich willkommen
heißen hier heute hahaha ich freue mich
schon so mega länder die ages hhm zeigt
seine bevor wir uns jetzt hier ins
abenteuer stürzen fragen sich jetzt
bestimmt einige die meinen kanal schon
länger verfolgen
luca du hast doch schon mal als lender
epages hochgeladen das ist richtig meine
damen und herren ich habe mir nur
gedacht dass ich jetzt eine kleine
horrorserie hier auf meinem kanal machen
werde und zwar immer wenn ihr eine
leitzahl erreicht die nicht vor gebe
dann werde ich eine woche später ein
neues video hochladen habe jetzt schon
angst deswegen meine damen und herren
wenn dieses video hier letztes mal die
70.000 schaffen dieses video 80.000
leicht schaffen sollte dann kommt
nächste woche ein neues horrorspiel und
das dürft ihr mir jetzt in die
kommentare schreiben was ich spielen
soll
hier klicken einfach mal auf star game
und wir sehen schon der bildschirm wird
schwarz hasek productions länder die
eight pages da geht es nämlich darum
dass wir in einem wald sind und wir
müssen ich weiß gar nicht mehr was die
steuerung sind horst escape to resume
space to quit
laut ages also wir müssen hier sind die
niederlage war weg die scheiße
wir befinden uns hingegen im wald und
wir können mit der rechten maustaste die
taschenlampe ausmachen wir können so ein
bisschen schneller rennen und müssen
acht seiten einsammeln wenn wir diese
acht seiten eingesammelt haben dann sind
wir in einem neuen level
ausländer ist es immer sehr kritisch
sich umzudrehen weil er immer hinter
einem sein könnte falls sie nicht wissen
wie das sender aussieht das ist glaube
ich würde das spiel am liebsten gerade
so kommentieren von wegen herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
simulator voll lustig und so aber es ist
leider dass länder und ich spiele das
sie gerade im vollbildmodus und es ist
komplett dunkel dieser ganze screen und
ich habe angst und ich habe angst
sagte ich bereits dass ich angst habe
die sache weiß länder als das wenn man
sich andere dass sein kürze das mit
einem strick
[Musik]
das ist der brand ich habe solche angst
hatte ich im spiel ohne spaß bevor
irgendwer in die kommentare schritte das
ist ja nur gespielt die argen
ich bin am schwitzen wie sonst was
gerade ich schwöre euch jetzt schon wenn
ich das nächste mal ein horror game
hochladen dann hole ich mir hier max
dazu oder irgendwann merkt auch angst
vor horror spiel das man gar keinen sinn
hole ich mir gegen den anderen youtuber
oder irgend einen kollegen oder was weiß
ich wer dann startet nämlich das team
zusammen machen damit ich mich zumindest
nicht alleine hier irgendwie fürchte
also ja aber mal zurück zum thema rot
was ist das so meine damen und herren
wir haben nie irgendwelche bäume
irgendwelche steine gefunden ich habe
mir damals die erste seite
hier steht litauen pages weight das
heißt ok bin ich glaube ich habe dieses
länder teil tatsächlich schon irgendwie
dreimal oder so auf einem kanal gebracht
und jedes mal wieder tief sich diese
spannung des todes in den arsch anfängt
ich habe mir extra ein handtuch liegen
damit ich mir den schweizer tropfen kann
auch leute ich schwöre euch wenn ich
mich jetzt umdrehen dann steht jetzt
hinter mir ich kann euch sagen ich kann
es euch sagen ich kann es fühlen dass er
da ist
er ist nicht da
aber gerade weniger licht
nähere mich ganz langsam der wald meine
damen und herren die seite klebt an
dieses was ist dessen penis die seite
klebt an diesen dingen und andere auf
der seite steht händlern das heißt ich
jetzt einfach mal hier drauf wir haben
die zweite seite eingesammelt und leute
jetzt kann ich euch stören wenn ich mich
jetzt umdrehen werde dann wird er hinter
mir stehen mein herz rast ich habe es so
angst vor dieser scheiße also wenn er
dabei hätte ich drehe mich mal wieder
oben
a
weiter da ist oder war da nicht immer
sobald der bildschirm anfängt christlich
zu werden heißt es dass das länder man
irgendwo in der nähe ist beziehungsweise
sich hinter einem befindet das war
gerade der fall jetzt gerade ist er
glaube ich nicht mehr bei mir ich weiß
nicht ob es schon wieder zeit sein
könnte aber ich glaube werde ich mich
umdrehe befindet er sich inter mir meine
damen also sind sind wenn ich mich jetzt
werde ich es jetzt ich hab die taschen
ab
[Applaus]
was ist das meine damen und herren das
ist das motto gott ich bin bei diesen
militärstützpunkt angekommen irgendwo
hier an irgend so eine pipeline befindet
sich nämlich noch eine seite und ich sag
euch das ist die dritte seite und danach
wird es nämlich so richtig spannend in
diesem scheiss hier ich weiß allerdings
nicht mehr wo sich die seite befindet
meine damen und herren aber ich würde
sagen ich mache jetzt eine ganz kurze
blutprobe und zwar drehe ich mich jetzt
einfach wo du hast gut reden da hinten
ich habe keine angst dass nun spiel das
sich jetzt nur spiele auf meinem das ist
ein spiel für leute die mögen hora
spiele
da machen wir das doch einfach mal für
die warum zulfic habe ich jetzt verloren
nur wenige minuten später heißt ich
contractor oder putzkräfte eigentlich
eher pussy kräfte aber ich will neue
nacht neues wird meine damen und herren
ich begebe mich wieder auf die suche
nach acht seiten dies ist gerade noch
relativ korrekt hier am start also wenn
ich tausend ab kreis träger ist lang da
ich glaube halt wirklich es ist so dass
sich taschenlampen mit dauer des spiels
an helligkeit verliert von deswegen
glaube ich jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen
oben das heißt wenn ihr das ist was das
denn schon wieder die scheiß wand wer
die taschenlampe einfach trotzdem an
lassen
also meine damen und herren haben noch
keine einzige seite gefunden das ist
eigentlich eine ganz tolle leistung
bisher das ding ist halt das andere
youtuber wenn sie horror spiele spielen
das ganze auch so hora mäßig aufbauen
soll ich das auch mal so machen wir
laufen auf ein auto zu was einfach
mitten in einem wald steht ich will
nicht wissen was in diesem auto schon
alles vorgefallen ist ob dort leute
vergewaltigt wurden ob dort kinder
misshandelt wurden oder sonst irgendwas
passiert ist aber wir sehen dieses auto
steht ja einfach schon um die türen
verschlossen zu sein aber eventuell
sich irgendwo hier hinten dran eine
seite oder sonstiges gegen wir sehen
schon pro download vortex erste seite
ist eingesammelt meinem team zuschauer
das heißt befinden uns nun in der gewalt
ist länder man also noch nicht der hat
uns noch nicht gekriegt isländer man hat
uns entdeckt ist uns auf den fersen er
weiß dass wir ihn bekämpfen wollen
beweisen dass wir auf der suche nach den
acht seiten sind man ich finde das
langweilig so zu kommentieren ich will
das ganze und wirklich mit meinen
emotionen kommentiert wir drehen uns
jetzt mal oben meine damen und herren
wir aber da war
der war da irgendwo die befinden uns
wieder auf der großen freien fläche die
körpers eigentlich immer so ein bisschen
zur orientierung dahin ist schon wieder
das map ende
da war die sache ist halt dass jetzt
gerade noch alles klar geht also werden
jetzt gerade eine seite eingesammelt im
durchgang vorhin hatten wir zwei seiten
eingesammelt es ist noch gar nicht so
schlimm wenn man später irgendwie ich
hab das ja auch schon mal durchgespielt
und wenn wir dann irgendwie bei der
sechsten siebten seite ist dann kann es
sein dass man sich einfach mal umdreht
und dann steht erhalten nicht irgendwie
relativ weit weg sondern er steht dann
halt direkt hinter allem
und das ist halt ekelhaft ich muss jetzt
mal so ein bisschen den zoom und hier so
ein bisschen rein zu schauen aber die
sache ist halt dass man hier nicht mal
irgendwie irgendwas erkennen kann doch
nicht sein jetzt bin ich eine vorne
wieder auf das schild profis länder mehr
was willst komm doch her irgendwo meine
herren gesangsverein alter das kann doch
nicht so schwer sein hier 18 verfickte
seiten zu finden ich verstehe nicht
wieso muss man hier haben mich schon
wieder pallas sicherheit nicht verstehe
ist einfach diese tatsache dass 08
bissingen din a 4 blätter finden muss
einem verlorenen wald um eine komische
person zu zell steuer das macht das sinn
ich habe jetzt gerade sogar echte taktik
also ich glaube die ganze zeit am rand
der map irgendwie her damit ich das
ganze feld irgendwie ein bisschen abgase
aber auch das bringt einfach nichts weil
irgendwo irgendwelche seiten hängen und
auf der steller men ist nicht am start
gerade es muss doch möglich sein dass
hier irgendwo eine beschissene seite
irgendwo hängt alter ich glaub da nicht
ohne grund gerade hier die ganze zeit am
rand der map her sollte eigentlich
wirklich so ein kurzes video werden wo
ich einfach sender men spiele vielleicht
ein paar seiten einsammeln und euch
frage was ihr von seiner horror serie
hat würde bei ausländern wenn es halt
wirklich so dass das leichteste beziehen
weil sie das am wenigsten horror volles
horror spielen wollt einfach so ein
bisschen die serie ankündigen wollte zu
sagen je 80.000 likes dann mache ich
einen neuen horror teil vielleicht mit
einem kumpel oder irgendwie so und bahn
befinde ich mich hier jetzt irgendwo und
sucht die ganze zeit vergeblich nach in
welchen seiten ich frage mich halt auf
die map von spiel zu spiel neu generiert
wird also ob das willst die minecraft
dass die teile einfach anders angeordnet
werden ja toll wieder das ende der map
also muss wirklich sagen würde es nicht
besonders groß warum stehst du denn
immer hinter mir
was soll ich tun alter wahrscheinlich
ist es wirklich so dass ich die ganze
zeit irgendwie unfreiwillig den ganzen
orten wo seiten sind einfach irgendwie
ausweiche und dem mich stattdessen
einfach hier im wald verlaufen
man fragt mich das aber passiert hier
noch mal irgendwas darf ich mich
vorstellen meine damen und herren ich
bin's luca der beschissenen horror game
spieler aller zeiten an dieser stelle
will ich jetzt aber das video beenden
ich bin gerade irgendwie einfach getötet
worden ich habe keine ahnung warum
wahrscheinlich habe ich einfach zu lange
gebraucht hat mit so viel die bauwagen
gekuckt fällt euch dieses video gefallen
hat dann lasse wie gesagt leica bei
80.000 likes werde ich nächste woche ein
neues horror spiel spielen ein viel
krassere was ihr in den kommentaren
bestimmen dürfe sonst findet ihr jetzt
hier um ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf schlägt könnte meinen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren
da oben ins online shop da gibt's
merchandise und hier unten ist ein
weiteres video verlinkt also checkt das
ab
ja